[Music]
pet parents need to be aware that there
are a lot of things in our own homes
that can hurt our furry friends
it's important to pet proof your home
just like you might baby proof your home
petronedologist charlotte reed joins us
with ideas to help out
good morning charlotte and introduce
your friends this morning
good morning sherry this is hammy and
he's a three-year-old english toy
spaniel and this
is wally and he is a three and a half
year old english toys panel
they're my new pet stars so let's talk
about pet proofing your home charlotte
uh
why is that so important that's a great
question pet proofing your home is
really an important maneuver to do
because
two things one you want to keep your pet
safe and you also don't want a huge
vet bill that can clean out your bank
account so by taking some simple steps
and being aware
from a dog and cat's point of view
you're going to keep your dog safe
and save money and there i guess there
are some common things that your dogs
and
and cats chew around the home or might
chew that we're not even aware of talk
about those
you know one of the actually interesting
items that dogs and cats you is the
remote control
and people think the remote control but
if you think about it when you hold the
remote control you tend to palm it when
you're watching the television
and the bodily oils from your hands get
on it so
also it's either on a low coffee table
or a side table where pets have easy
access to either from the ground or
climbing up on the couch
and getting the remote control you don't
want them to ingest the plastic
and as well as the batteries which can
cause cause burns in their mouths
so it's really important to keep the
remote control high up place it on a
media table right near the television
and that way they won't get to it
well there seems to be a high rate of
problems with pets getting into our
medication
does that happen a lot it really does
and i'm glad that you brought that up
a lot of times human medication and pet
medication will be stored together
and i suggest don't store your
medication together
because a lot of times you can give your
dog human medication
as well as you can take your pet's
medication so you don't want to
do that that can cause pure catastrophe
so it's really good idea to make sure
that your vet for example i have two
bottles right here
the pet bottle is in a blue canister my
vet
uses blue canisters so you don't make
that mistake also the top of the lid has
a dog and a cat on it
and most medication is stored in these
kind of clear
kind of auburn color bottles so separate
the medication and then you don't have
to worry
you know the best thing for people to do
pet owners to do is to go through every
room of the house and think like a dog
and think like a cat
where can they climb what can they knock
over whether it's a shelf
with a vise or any glassware or even in
the backyard
for example if your yard guy is coming
in the summertime you know make sure
that your pets are not out on the grass
make sure the plants that you have in
the backyard
and even in the garage a very curious
place remember our creatures are curious
they want to be where you are
so they're going to follow you around
the house even if that means the garage
so baby proof locks are really great
ideas you want to keep bedroom doors
closed you want to keep bathroom doors
closed
and also keep those toilet lids down all
great advice charlotte thank you so much
always good to see you and we'll talk to
you again love all thank you so much for
having me you bet take care